alexandre baghanya never knows when the
next prison riot will break out
she lives across the street from
guayaquil's infamous state penitentiary
from over there you can hear the victim
screams the cries for help it's
terrifying and when the prisoners
explode dynamite you jump from the bed
late last year it took police days to
enter the penitentiary after 118 inmates
were hacked to death and set on fire in
a battle between rival drug gangs
ecuador has become a sanctuary for the
multi-billion dollar narcotics trade
it's run from prisons like this one by
local drug lords
but also by international criminal
organizations like albania's
companiabello
its leader is alleged to be controlling
the export of tons of cocaine from this
ecuadorian jail where he's serving a
13-year sentence
it all starts here
we went on a patrol with special forces
police in guayaquil where gang violence
is
soaring neighborhoods like this one
provide the cannon fodder for criminal
organizations people who live in poverty
and who have little hope of ever finding
a dignified job are willing and able to
help criminal organizations from abroad
export their wares from ecuador to the
rest of the world
ecuador's geographic position and the
use of the us dollar for its currency
make it ideal for drug cartels
luscious tropical fruits especially
bananas are exported from guayaquil
specific ports to europe asia and russia
so far this year more than 300 tons of
cocaine have been confiscated in cargo
but ecuadorian experts estimate that's
less than 30 percent of what gets
through
small fishing boats like these and
homemade submarines also take colombian
cocaine north
it's a short trip from guayaquil to
central america and mexico from where
the sinaloa and gulf cartels take the
cargo across the u.s border
security minister diego ordonez tells us
that years of permissiveness tolerance
and corruption have made all this
possible
the problem is that the narcotics trade
has penetrated politics it's penetrated
the administration of justice that's why
i say we are facing a serious threat to
the very stability of the state
the government has imposed a month-long
state of emergency in the guayaquil area
but that will clearly be insufficient to
address the crisis much less the social
problems that nourish it
lucia newman al jazeera guayaquil
ecuador